wir kommen zu einem fall der geht gut
aus wir haben victoria müller in dieser
sendung schon mal gehabt sie hat sich
fürchterlich aufgeregt über einen
hotelier der für sie eine hochzeit
geplant hat und frau müller ist uns
jetzt zugeschaltet hallo da ist und wir
haben das thema besprochen auch mit an
kempkens zusammen da geht es darum ein
hotelier hat mit ihnen einen termin
vereinbart sie haben aber jetzt nicht so
viel lust auf die hochzeit weil sie
haben uns gesagt bei einer hochzeit da
umarmt man sich auf und da sind dass mit
den abstandsregelungen ist halt
irgendwie wie schwierig und wir haben
dann ich hab es ihnen auch in dieser
sendung versprochen und wir halten
unsere versprechen
ich habe ihnen versprochen wir kümmern
uns drum wir haben also sehr lange auch
mit dem hotelier der nicht vor die
kamera wollte und seinem anwalt
gesprochen und tatsächlich ist es uns
gelungen ist sie hatten glaube ich 1000
euro angezahlt und der hotelier ist
jetzt bereit tatsächlich nur 50 euro
stornogebühr zu kassieren
zuerst war es so dass er praktisch die
1000 euro von ihnen behalten wollte ist
das nicht toll das ist super und ich
toll
haben sie damit gerechnet dass sich
dieser fall so wendet nein hätte ich
nicht weil ja das bitte mal geht es in
der stimmung bin und das dritte mal um
hilfe bitten weil ich alleine nicht
weitergekommen bin endlich jetzt damit
gerechnet dass die 1000 euro einfach
verloren gegangen sind und umso mehr
freue ich mich jetzt dass sie so viel
rausholen konnten und das geht mir so
oft ihr offenes ohr an geliehen haben
und erkenntnis mehr so viele tipps
gegeben hat und ich habe versucht alles
umzusetzen und trotzdem habe ich gedacht
es ist schon fast verloren gewesen aber
viel hindern